eh bien
je devrais aller
tu travailles je suis vraiment silencieux
oh ouais
parfois tu es important là
-bas moi non
bruno même si c'est lui qui a le
poteau
hein
il m'a trouvé le travail il y a longtemps
c'est tellement étrange
c'est beaucoup plus petit que je ne m'en
souvenais  endroit où
vous avez été ici avant
euh ouais
c'est mon cousin si vous pouvez le croire
nos familles sont venues ici sur un bateau
ensemble
nous avons grandi ici
vous savez bruno et moi étions proches
mais ensuite ça a changé
curieux
comment est-ce que tu as fini  travailler avec
lui de toute façon
il m'a amené ici
ils voulaient me renvoyer mais
il l'a fait pour que je puisse rester
ma famille ici
ils ne veulent pas de moi alors
wow
je suis désolé pour ta famille
écoute
j'ai
vu beaucoup de filles  dans votre situation,
laissez-moi vous dire que peu importe ce que
vous faites,
ma mère
me disait toujours
les yeux de Dieu sur chaque moineau,
vous avez le droit d'être heureux,
du moins c'est ce que je pense